sir I am a huge fan of your work I
absolutely thrilled to be talking with
you today thank you so much I just wish
I had more time so in the future you
know so um a million questions for you
there's going to be people out there
that have never seen one of your movies
if they haven't what is the first film
you would like them watching and why wow
um well they could start with Ferrari
then maybe they should go
to heat then from that they go to last
the moans and then they should go to
Insider and then they should come back
to Ferrari and see the second time right
how do you feel when a journalist
sitting across from you at a junket is
wearing a bootleg shirt from one of your
movies I think it's very ironic because
I've been asked a whole bunch of
questions that in heat the coffee shop
scene which by the way is is an event
that really occurred in real life uh
when alen and Bob were facing each other
for some reason there was some rumor
that they weren't actually there at the
same time I don't know why everybody
thought that what it was there's
actually three cameras and what you're
wearing on your chest is what the third
camera was shooting which is the profile
two shot but I never used it because
every time I went to that shot it became
it removed us and made us observers of
the two men instead of being
empathetically subjectively inside that
dialogue so I always only use the uh two
overs because everything we did was at
this simultaneous simultaneous I had two
cameras set up just out of re just out
of sight of each other shooting that uh
shooting that that scene I could ask you
literally an hour worth of questions
about this movie but I am curious I'm
fascinated by the editing process
because it's where it all comes together
right which of your films changed the
most in the editing room in ways you
didn't expect going in none of them uh
it's it's the the what is what the film
is supposed to do to you and and the by
the end and then what the you know the
end of the third Act is supposed to do
to set up the end and the end of the
second act to set up the third act
that's engraved in stone and so the
editing is to
realize that overall writing objective
so it it uh I'm very big I'm a big
believer in story structure it almost as
if you could take the the totally
organic subjective experience of seeing
a movie and put it under an x-ray
machine you'll see the bone there's a
structure like a skeleton if that's
broken then the movie is not going to
work and so um so the objective how I
want you to feel do I want you to feel
suspense do I want you to feel the
irresolution like in Ferrari what the
hell's going to happen um is he going to
uh is is the m media this Thousand Mile
Race Across all of Italy across all
kinds of crazy roads through cities
through towns um is Ferrari going to win
or not win and then then there's a
double ending to that there's a tragedy
and a Triumph
simultaneously and um and he may be
ruined and he's got a confrontation with
his wife and so that sense of a
resolution that is absolutely has to be
achieved and so when I shoot it I'm
trying to achieve it in a shooting and
make sure I have it there but everything
comes together ultimately in the editing
room and that's where it's um and so you
know that's where we try to deliver it
then again when I'm mixing The Sounds um
the music and fox and everything else
man I have so many questions about
Ferrari but I guess ultimately what is
it what was it about this material and
this story that said I absolutely need
to make this the real people and that it
resonated so strongly with this is this
is life this is how life really is it's
complex it's complicated it's a man with
with uh with a a wife who's in mourning
because they both lost their son Dino a
year ago and meanwhile he has a
completely second family the most of Oda
knows about but his wife doesn't and uh
that happened during the chaos of the
end of second world war and he has a
12-year-old illegitimate son um you know
he's bound and and has a connection to
his wife that's that's in they're
Inseparable but they can't live together
and they can't live apart and he also
only is at home with Len lardy and his
son Pierro and these kind of irr
resolved conflicts the movie is filled
with that so it was so atypical of the
kind of
formulaic way character are sometimes
built and dramas play out so it was it
was that quality about and it's all true
and it all happen to collide in these
four intense months three or four
intense months in in in 1957 where the
future the factories riding on this race
drivers he's close to are killed the
death rate during that period of time
was horrendous it about
50% so the the um but all of those you
know that was unique it's a unique story
basically it's a deep dive behind the
iconic and screwable facade of Enzo
Ferrari into all of the Technicolor and
melodrama you know that was that was
that's really going on in his life sir I
really want to thank you for all of your
films and your work and thank you so
much for talking with me today my
pleasure